President Biden's open border policies
are not only igniting National Security
concerns they're fueling America's crime
crisis we have new video of yet another
violent migrant attack and you will not
believe this one this video doorbell
footage shows a migrant stealing a
pro-israel flag from a Jewish family's
Long Island home and one of the members
of this family by the way lost a
relative in the October 7th terrorist
attack by Hamas and there you see this
individual taking that pro-israel flag
that homeowner rushed to get his flag
back but the migrant immediately began
punching him in the head you see it
there put him in a choke hold headbutted
him at least once that's all according
to the homeowner and threw him to the
ground that migrant has been arrested
and charged with a hate crime
authorities say he's a Palestinian from
North Africa that's how he
self-described and he got into the US
illegally from Mexico back in November
at one point the attacker repeated
anti-semitic slurs and was caught
flipping the bird to a camera that's
becoming somewhat of a trend among these
criminals it was just like the migrant
accused of attacking two NYPD officers
what an image the New York County
Executive who announced the arrest
summed up what many Americans are
feeling right
now we have a
crisis these are not the type of people
who to America like my great
grandparents did like your great
grandparents and grandparents and
parents who came to America to kiss the
ground instead they spit on our flag
they trample on our values and they
commit crimes and they do so at taxpayer
expense this Insanity has to
stop I just want to pull up that side by
side because it's so stunning so this
guy comes through the Mexico border and
November commits an alleged hate crime
against a man who lost a relative in the
ooco October 7th attack and Leslie look
at what they both do they're both
flipping the bird this is the New York
City Cop attacker and then there you
have the migrant and this alleged hate
crime this is a trend in Joe Biden's
America I would say sadly um th this is
a trend but it's not just a trend among
illegal immigrants there are three
Palestinian students in Vermont one who
is now paralyzed the perpetrator an
American citizen there was a little boy
who was stabbed 26 times to death
because he was Muslim these are just two
examples there's horrific attacks
against Jewish people there's horrific
attacks against against musl people
cross their B illegally are and not all
and not all by migrants again something
has to be done absolutely I have always
agreed with this no matter who was
president no matter which party was in
power something has to be done about
immigration not just because it's an
election year because it is a problem
and it does contribute to Crime but but
the numbers show that the majority of
crimes and violent crimes are committ by
American those are apples and oranges
and and of course we have space in our
hearts to mourn those who are hurt in
every type of crime particularly what
would look to be a hate crime this is
about coming to this country and
demanding that the food they're being
given for free isn't good enough this is
about coming to this country and
crawling through space is undetected so
that they can break more laws when they
get here because otherwise they would go
through a Port of Entry that's not what
what you're talking about is whether or
not we have space to see that Muslims
are hurt too that's not what this is
about what this is about is when people
break our laws they put their middle
fingers up to the cameras I mean that
that's what kayle's pointing out and
what they have in common is the way they
got here that's what we're talking about
right now and if you want to stop that
that's going to be a different type of a
of a a plan than to stop the two
examples that you gave the type here you
Clos the Border you get caught up on the
last three years of 8 million people
coming into the country you get caught
up on your on your justices being able
to go through which claims are Asylum
and and which people need to be deported
right away of course you know how I feel
if you came illegally we send you back
and you figure out how to do it the
legal way and Emily get to the back of
the line the homeowner who is the victim
of this hate crime I I want him to be
able to speak here he said this is
happening because of open borders and
before letting people in we need to see
their backgrounds we need to protect our
country our citizens our taxpayers
straight from the mouth of the victim of
course it is look at that the the video
of of your neighbor of my neighbor being
attacked on his lawn that is not only an
assault but it's an attack on on all of
America isn't that the whole point that
we're talking about that that flagrance
the absolute lack of respect the lack of
respect for a commander-in-chief's words
of deterrence the lack of respect for
anyone trying to enforce the laws those
police who whose salaries we pay that
are in danger every day to show up and
arrest this guy he's facing over four
charges who do you think is going to pay
for his three Square meals a day in
prison or in jail us we are exactly and
the whole point is that as he said too
if I see the flag of the people that
killed my people there will be a problem
that's what the Palestinian guy said um
in the police report oh there there's
going to be a problem to you there's a
problem now to all of us Americans it is
illegal immigration and it is the fact
that with every breath of this
commander-in-chief Americans are being
prioritized last and that attack is just
the tip of the iceberg when is it going
to be you or your neighbor next you know
you tying together the problem with the
border with the problem of the fact that
the country itself has gone to Great
hatred and division is opposed to inclus
inclusivity which we were founded on of
course people that come here illegally
aren't even understand the the
background of this country not to
mention the fact that the hate crime
against Israel against the the Jewish
person on Long Island there there was
hideous cuz it was against all Jews and
it isn't just that we can't make a moral
equivalency and say okay this one's
against Jews that one's against
Palestinians because you have to
understand what October 7th was which
was part of a much larger problem of
people that don't believe Jews should
exist or Israel should exist that's
where that comes from so we have to rail
against that and then of course we also
should be against hate crimes of all
time we need to go towards kindness and
inclusivity well at least I'm glad to
report the guy who committed the hate
crime was held on $50,000 bail so not a
lawless da there that was a second part
of this story some da still follow the
law hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch
me and my co-hosts Harris vulner and
Kaylee mcki on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights